from the badlands come the orcs and
goblins a green tide of brutal creatures
that must be stopped
hey everyone its Peter Brown standing in
for freelance writer Daniel Starkey for
his review of total war Warhammer the
Total War series has until now balanced
historical realism with strategic play
Warhammer however has always been about
tactics and for more than 30 years it's
been one of the most popular fantasy
settings around with a rich lore and
vibrant tournament scene for its
tabletop miniature game the mixture of
the two in total war Warhammer is a
sight to behold not only is it one of
the most faithful adaptions of
warhammers mythos it is also far and
away the best Total War has ever been
the Empire has ever been besieged by
foes but you are a prince of Altaf
greatness runs in your very blood with
the addition of irresponsibly large
cannons apparitions gyrocopters and
powerful spells the amount of time you
need to spend learning what you and your
foes can bring to bear in the
battlefield is staggering but these
fights don't get old part of that comes
from how distinct all of the main
factions are the Empire is a Romanesque
monolithic force they are organized
effective generalists Bertoni ins and
our 13 band of humans uses pegasi and
holy lances to cleanse evil then the
green skins pull from warhammers own
brand of classic fantasy orcs and
goblins silly obnoxious and bloodthirsty
they come with complex internal politics
if you're not waging enough war measured
by a stack called fight eNOS other
factions will sprout and make with the
killing that you have it vampire counts
are genuine undead faction they bolster
their lines by draining life from others
and reviving the dead from massive
battles dwarves are their opposite with
heavily armored and armed troops they
pull in staunch defenders that will hold
a battle line long enough for their
enemies to be ripped to shreds with
machine guns and cannon fire each
faction offers a bevy of gameplay
options that mesh and there's no one
right way to play but leaning into their
strengths and mixing it up with the
occasional oddball tactic works well
that's supported with magic which can
turn the tide of all kinds of fights as
a result you're faced with a choice in
how you protect the magic wielding Lords
and maximize their potential without
risking a loss campaigns throw even more
variables into that mix like previous
total war games you can take command of
a country and balance your time managing
economies cultures and individual
battles here things go from beautifully
intricate to elaborate masterstroke each
of the four major factions have their
own campaigns with major battles quests
and goals
unlike previous total war games where
you'd have a smattering of small
distinctions to separate each group
these races are truly distinct vampires
are reviled by the living and have a
hard time with diplomacy to survive and
remain stable they have to poison and
corrupt the land in front of them doors
and green skins can travel underground
and have constructed settlements that
only they can capture each of these
pieces works together and helps texture
the overarching narrative at first these
races push their own petty agendas but
as the Game of Thrones II threat grows
in the north you can try to band
together with the others and hold off
the impending invasion at the same time
you'll have proximal race dependent
goals for victory which strain how
you'll manage these larger threats as
these campaigns progress you'll have to
manage multiple conflicts on many fronts
putting your skills to the test in a
variety of ways total war Warhammer is
an interlocking network of very smart
decisions and integrating the Warhammer
universe with total wars systems was the
first massive battles are more
challenging because of the addition of
magic and flying units a new brands of
artillery and soldiers keep you changing
up your approach
total war Warhammer has also seen a
massive upgrade to its AI where before
you might see an AI opponent rush you
when you had a strong defensive position
now the CPU will employ advanced flaking
maneuvers or use cavalry to pull away
key defenders the audio design - has
picked up an interesting overhaul and
it's more noteworthy than ever because
of the fantasy elements at play we know
what a Roman Gladius striking a rawhide
shield sounds like we can create that
sound here in the real world but what
about a door of an organ gun what about
the off-kilter shuffle of orcish armor
there's no proper equivalent and that
goes for the vampire counts monstrosity
x' and the demons that form the ranks of
warriors of chaos in every case these
combatants sound glorious
the things that carryover from total war
to haven't just been improved
they've been damn near mastered but my
complaints from a few years ago with
Total War 2's camera still hold when
pulling the camera out to get a better
view you can't go very far before the
game switches to a full overhead
perspective that can be somewhat
troublesome and limit how much of any
given battle you can see at once but
it's only a minor frustration total war
has always been about balance between
strategy and tactics realism and
engaging play warhammers characters in
its history and its creativity is a shot
in the arm for the series you'll be
tested on all fronts and asked to manage
complex battles with broad but nuanced
outcomes
every system and piece feeds into others
and your choices make all of the
difference it's a triumph of real-time
strategy design and the best Total War
has ever been whoa is upon us
it is unending